jetzt eine einschätzung von unserem
kollegen julian rötker
[Musik]
auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische lage in der gesamten
ukraine angucken und leider gehört dazu
auch das kriegsverbrechen vom buch das
massaker was dort begangen wurde und
dazu gibt es neue informationen
wir haben uns nochmal genau mit den mit
den zeugen dort vor ort sozusagen
besprochen haben uns angehört was die
dazu gesagt haben und es ist eben noch
nicht ganz klar wer diese menschen dort
am straßenrand auf beiden seiten der
straße beispielsweise erschossen hat es
gibt verschiedene angaben aber die die
sage ich mal die möglichen verdächtigen
werden immer immer genauer und zwar
haben wir einmal die informationen von
zeugen dass es kadyrov leute waren leute
aus tschetschenien die gesagt haben wir
sind von condor wir sind hier um euch zu
befreien und dann aber eben menschen
erschossen haben dem widerspricht so ein
bisschen dass die die fahrzeuge dieser
täter dort asv getragen haben sollen wir
wissen es gibt verschiedene buchstaben
beispielsweise das z das oder das v und
dass v ist die russische marine
infanterie die kommt aber nicht aus
tschetschenien sondern aus anderen
gebieten insofern gibt es hier
verschiedene spuren eine letzte spur ist
das eine einheit aus raaba rovs im
fernen osten russlands hier aktiv
gewesen sein soll das ist wiederum die
schützen brigade die also weder kadyrov
ist noch marineinfanterie aber zumindest
aus diesen ganzen wust von möglichen
tätern aus russland gibt es verschiedene
gruppen mittlerweile die sich hier
herauskristallisieren die also dort
mindestens 20 menschen vielleicht 50 60
menschen dort getötet haben auch heute
morgen neue bilder von erschossenen
ukrainern dort in butter rund um mutter
die dort gefunden wurden in einem hof in
einem keller die dort zuerst offenbar
vernommen wurden oder verhört wurden
gefesselt wurden und dann umgebracht
wurden dass die lage in butter wir
müssen es aber die gesamte ukraine
aktuelle situation ansehen denn dort
ändert sich extrem viel ausputzer wissen
wir nur was dort passiert ist weil die
russen dort vor drei tagen etwa komplett
abgezogen sind und wir wollen dass ein
markieren die sind nicht bloß aus
butscher abgezogen sondern aus dem
gesamten norden der ukraine wir haben
also ich diesen vorstoß cup vor kiew der
der sozusagen war die alle abgezogen
sind wir wissen dass auch cerny vier
auch die russen komplett abgezogen sind
und hier noch mal ihm droht aber auch
hier aus sumy wissen wir heute morgen
sind die russen komplett abgezogen das
heißt die gesamte armee zieht sich
zurück neue aufnahme aus belarus heute
morgen zeigen wie die russischen
soldaten aus belarus wiederum nach
russland fahren das heißt man hört dort
auf man gibt aber keinesfalls die
ukraine auf man versucht jetzt den osten
aber ich versuche es mal zu kennzeichnen
hier den osten anzugreifen und
einzunehmen das ist dieses gebiet was
wir hier sehen da haben wir die region
donetsk und lugansk wo die russische
offensive weiter geht und immer aktiver
wird wir wollen das mal zeigen auf der
karte das sind neue bisschen was im
video das sind aufnahmen von russischer
seite das ist die stadt kobe in der
region lugansk dort haben wir erbitterte
häuser schlachten dort also der neue
focus der russischen armee wir sehen
hier russische panzer mit dem z die
durch die straßen fahren und dort eben
aktiv sind tropische schon dreimal
angeblich von den russen erobert immer
wieder haben die ukraine ein teil davon
zurückerobert und hier gehen die extrem
schweren kämpfen weiter hier sehen wir
die russischen soldaten teilweise so
genannte volks republikaner also diese
marionettenregime des kreml die dort
aktiv sind die kämpfen hier in den
straßen von tropischen versuchen diese
stadt zu erobern und dort genau dort ist
sozusagen die neue entscheidungsschlacht
wenn man so möchte also die russland
zieht aus dem norden der ukraine abzieht
von kiew ab will aber unbedingt diesen
don't ask komplett unter seine kontrolle
bringen
da sieht es ziemlich ziemlich schlecht
aus muss man sagen ist für die ukrainer
da werden die weiter zurückgedrängt es
gibt aber auch hoffnungsschimmer wir
sehen dass man ein video aus archiv an
das aus easy easy um ist ganz in der
nähe des donbass also direkt nördlich
davon da haben wir ein video von gestern
wir sehen hier ein russisches flugzeug
was abstürzt ich mach's nochmal kurz
zurück ein russisches flugzeug was
abgeschossen wurde eben gerade von der
ukrainischen armee was jetzt hier
abstürzt und in den wäldern bei easy um
nur wenige kilometer nördlich des dorfes
sozusagen in flammen aufgeht qualität
wird gleich etwas besser und das
besondere ist wir wissen anhand des
wracks mittlerweile um was für ein
flugzeug es sich handelt nämlich um
12 35 ein absolut modernes rosig das
kampfflugzeug was hier abgeschossen
wurde wir lassen wie man große laufen
woher wissen wir dass das wrack wurde
gefilmt von einer organischen drohne und
das wrack ist relativ eindeutig wenn wir
ansehen wie das aufgebaut ist das ist
eine super es um 35 die erst 1989
überhaupt gebaut wurde dann mit die
ukrainer so ein flugzeug abschießen
können brauchen sie moderne waffen und
offenbar haben sie moderne waffen
mittlerweile waffen des westens die
dorthin geliefert wurden und die von der
ukraine mittlerweile benutzt werden um
dort vorzugehen insofern die lage im
osten extrem schwierig für die
organischen truppen sie es ging ja einen
absoluten übermacht russische einheiten
entgegen immer mehr auch kommt vom tier
vom norden haben wir gesagt um die
ukraine herumkommen wieder neu in den
bass aber und das ist die hoffnung
mittlerweile haben die organischen
truppen hier die waffen die sie brauchen
um die russischen panzer aber auch die
russischen kampfflugzeuge abzuschießen
und sich gegen diese übermacht und diese
invasion aus dem osten zu wehr zu setzen
[Musik]